The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, it's time
to get started.
Pay attention to the
clicker questions.
All right, I'll give you
10 more seconds.
Not bad, we seem to
be in the 70's.
All right.
So if you didn't have time to
click in, let's consider
what's going on here.
What's true about the
relationship of q and k here?
So is q less than or
greater than k?
Less than.
And so you have to think about
what that means in terms of
where we are now in the
reaction and where the
reaction is at equilibrium, and
I like to think about it
in terms of products -- are
there more products now, or
are there more products
at equilibrium.
So if q is less than k, then
there are more products at
equilibrium, and so
the reaction will
shift toward products.
So it's going to move in
the direction to reach
equilibrium, since k is a bigger
number than q, and both
of these terms are products over
reactants, there'd mean
there's more product at
equilibrium then there are
now, and so the reaction
is going to
shift toward products.
All right, so we're at 73%.
Let's see if by the end of
today, we can get up to 90 on
these kinds of questions.
All right, so we're going to
continue to consider external
effects on k in today's class.
I also wanted to mention that
on each of the handouts for
the lectures, I have the
corresponding reading material
listed on the handout, and
I've listed it as section
numbers in the chapters rather
than page numbers, so that's a
little bit of a difference.
And the reason why I've done
that is that we've had many
different versions of the book
in this class, and they don't
seem to change the section
titles or the section numbers,
but they do change the page
numbers associated with them.
So if I give you section numbers
then you should be
able to use of whichever
version of the book is
available to you.
So that's how I have it listed
now, and the reading
assignment is also listed on
each problem-set as well.
So when you're going over the
handouts later studying for
the exam, you can see where in
the book this particular
lecture, the material
is, so you can
go and do that reading.
All right, so we talked at the
end of the class last time
about the Le Chatelier's
principle, and this is a
principle that you can use to
predict the direction of
change of a reaction -- whether
it'll shift to the
right or shift to the left.
And simply stated, that systems
tend to respond in
such a way to minimize
the stress.
So if something is added to
the reaction, the reaction
will shift in a way to minimize
that stress caused by
the thing that's added
to the system.
So, we talked about adding
reagents and removing products
last time, and now we're going
to go on and talk about what
happens when you change
the volume.
So if you have a system at
equilibrium and you change the
volume of it, and here in
particular we're talking about
a gaseous system, what's
going to happen?
So what do we know
about volumes
when it comes to gases?
We say that a decrease in volume
of the gaseous system
causes an increase in
total pressure.
What equation leaps to your mind
when I say those words?
Exactly, p v equals n r t.
Yes.
So there's a relationship
between pressure and volume --
n is the number of moles, r is
our gas constant, and t is our
temperature.
This is one of the things that
usually sticks from high
school, and if you haven't seen
it before, it's pretty
easy to get up to speed
with this equation.
So Le Chatelier's principle then
predicts that the system
will respond if possible
in a way to
reduce the total pressure.
So if you decrease the volume
and you cause an increase in
total pressure, Le Chatelier
says wait a minute, the system
wants to respond to minimize
that stress, so that it's
going to respond in such a way
to reduce that total pressure.
So let's look at some
examples of this.
So we have an example of a
reaction where we have two
moles of p 2 gas going to one
mole going to p 4 gas.
And I have a little cartoon
here to show this.
So we have our p 4 gas up
here, and our p 2 gas.
All right, so what's going to
happen if we're going to
change the volume
of this system?
So if we're going to decrease
the volume of the system, then
the reaction should shift
toward products.
So let's think about that.
So here in the middle we have
our sort of system, and then
on one side what happens when
you decrease the volume and on
the other side we're expanding
the volume.
So first, let's consider our
system when we're going to
compress that volume, decrease
that volume.
So what would be true is that
the system's going to respond
in such a way to minimize that
stress that has been put
forward by decreasing the
volume, and you're going to
try to compensate for that,
and in this case you can
compensate by a shift
toward products.
Why is that?
Well, it all has to do with
the stoichiometry of this
equation up here.
So for every two moles
of reactants, you
get one mole of products.
So if you shift from the two to
the one, that will cause a
decrease in pressure, and so
that will help compensate for
the increase in pressure
caused by
the switch in volume.
So you're going to respond in
such a way to compensate for
that stress.
So a shift to the reaction
to the right
decreases the total pressure.
So now let's think more about
why this is true.
Let's think about it from a math
perspective and also just
this qualitative perspective.
So let's consider it in
terms of q and k.
So suppose our volume is
decreased by a factor of 2,
let's just make it
easy, and we have
constant temperature here.
So this change will increase the
partial pressure of both
gases, the reacting gas and
the product gas, and it's
going to increase them
both by the same
amount, by 2 initially.
So let's look at our equation
for q, the reaction quotient.
We have partial pressure of
products over the partial
pressures of the reactants, a
raise to the coefficient to
the equation.
So initially you're going to
increase the pressure, partial
pressure of both gases by 2 --
then your product by 2, the
reactant by 2 -- but here
it's 2 squared.
So overall, q becomes 1/2.
So q decreases by a factor
of 2, and so q
becomes less then k.
And so, in the clicker question,
we talked about what
happens when q becomes less than
k, and what happens there
is you're going to shift
toward products
until q equals k again.
So you can think about this in
terms of q and k, and you can
also just think about it how
many moles of gas are on one
side, how many mold of gas on
the other side, and how are
you going to correspond, how are
you going to decrease or
minimize the stress
on the system.
All right, so let's think
about what happens if we
increase the volume, so here
is our system and now we're
going to expand it.
If we're going to increase the
volume, what's going to happen
to the total pressure?
I'm hearing it, but I want
everyone to answer.
Thank you.
All right, so it will decrease
the pressure.
And what that's going to do
is shift toward reactants,
because we want to compensate
for that decrease in pressure,
and to do that, we can increase
the pressure by
switching or shifting the
reaction toward the reactants.
So again, we're going from one
mole of product on one side to
two of the reactants.
So here, we see a shift
toward the reactants.
And so, this shift to the left
is going to increase the total
pressure to compensate for the
decrease in pressure that was
a result of this applied
force to the system.
And we could do this again
in terms of q and k.
Now we're going to get
a little trickier.
What happens if we add an
inert gas to a system
increasing the total pressure
at constant temperature?
So we're not adding one of the
reactants or one of the
products, we're adding an
inert gas, and we're
increasing the total pressure.
What's going to happen?
There's a couple of options,
what do you think?
How about nothing.
Why would nothing happen?
Well, q depends on the partial
pressure of the reactant gas
and the product gas.
And in this particular example,
the partial pressures
are not changing.
We are changing the total
pressure of the system by
adding an inert gas,
but we're not
changing the partial pressure.
So let's take this opportunity
to review partial pressures,
or if you haven't seen it
before, I'm going to tell you
everything you need to know
about partial pressures.
So here's a little review,
or for the first time,
description of partial
pressure.
So what is the definition?
The partial pressure is the
pressure that each gas would
exert if it were present
alone in the container.
So in this example, we have
oxygen in a container, and we
have one atmosphere
of pressure.
In the second one there's
nitrogen in the container with
one atomosphere of pressure.
If you put this amount of oxygen
and this amount of
nitrogen together in a
container, then you would have
two atmospheres of total
pressure, but you're still
going to have one atmosphere
of partial pressure for
oxygen, and one atmosphere of
partial pressure for nitrogen.
So it's as if the gas is
alone in the container.
That's the definition
of partial pressure.
So let's look at
some equations.
So the partial pressure of a
gas, p to sub a, is equal to
the number of moles of that gas,
and we also have in this
equation, r, our gas
constant, t, our
temperature, and v, our volume.
The total pressure on the
system, which is what this two
atmospheres is, is equal to the
partial pressure of gas a,
which would be the partial
pressure of the oxygen at one
atmosphere, the partial pressure
of the nitrogen at
one atmosphere, that's
all we have here.
So the partial pressure of those
two, of one plus one, we
have two for a total.
And that's equal to the total
number of the moles.
So in these problems, we're
going to be considering
partial pressure, and the
question you're going to be
asking yourself in all of these
different wordings of
the question is is the partial
pressure of the gas changing?
That's a very important question
to ask because
that'll help you answer the
questions correctly.
So let's go back to the original
question, what
happens if an inert gas is
added to the container,
increasing the total pressure
at constant temperature?
And the answer is nothing,
because q is not affected,
because q depends on the partial
pressures, and the
partial pressure
isn't changing.
We aren't changing the number
of moles of the gas in
question, we're just changing
the total pressure of the
system, we're adding
an inert gas.
And because partial pressures
don't change, q doesn't
change, and if q doesn't change,
there's no response
from the system.
So a lot of the questions in
this unit, they're not
actually very difficult, but
the wording can be tricky.
And so when you're doing these
problems, you have to be
thinking about what is changing
and what isn't
changing to be able to get
these questions correct.
And if you do that, then these
are some nice questions for
you to get right on the exams --
they're short, they're good
questions to go after.
All right.
Let's see how you're
doing with this.
What happens if an inert gas is
added to the container, but
the total pressure is
now kept constant,
temperature is also constant.
So let's think about this.
OK, let's take 10
more seconds.
OK, we're going down into the
60's -- again, we're heading
toward the 90's by the end,
but this is actually new
material, so that's fine.
All right, so let's
think about it.
So the reaction's going to
shift toward reactants.
Let's think about why,
let's break it down.
And what was important is that
hint that for the pressure to
be kept constant, the
volume of the
container must have increased.
So let's take a look at that.
So if the total pressure was
kept constant, if the total
pressure didn't change when you
added an inert gas, the
volume must have changed.
Let's look at this.
Say oxygen is our gas
of interest, and n
2 is an inert gas.
If we added an inert gas to our
system, the total pressure
should go up.
If it doesn't, then something
else must have changed, and
what must have changed
is the volume.
Otherwise the total
pressure would not
have stayed the same.
So the volume of the container
must have increased if the
pressure is the same.
So then we asked the question,
if you increase the volume,
what happens to the reaction,
how does it shift?
If you increase the volume, if
you expand the volume, then
you're going to shift from, in
this case where you have one
mole to two moles toward
reactants, you will, as the
volume increases, then you're
going to have a change in the
partial pressure of the gas --
all of a sudden the gas has a
lot more room, and its pressure
is going to decrease,
the partial pressure
will decrease.
It has a lot more space for
itself -- it's like it's in
there all by itself.
Partial pressure, you can think
of it as selfish gas
molecules, they don't care
what else is there.
They're only thinking about how
they're fairing in this
environment.
So then we want to shift in a
way that compensates for that
stress that increases the
pressure, so we move from one
molecule to two molecules.
So it's all about the partial
pressure q and k.
So again in these questions
you have to dissect
what's going on.
What has changed?
The questions are often
phrased in such a way,
something's kept constant, but
if something's kept constant,
you have to ask the question,
to keep it constant, did
something have to change
for that to be true.
So again, the wordings of
these can be tricky.
Do you have a question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So, the question is
is it necessary for it to try
to increase pressure.
This is just the predictive
tool of Le Chatelier.
Le Chatelier would predict that
if the system has changed
in such a way, such as volume
increases so the partial
pressure decreases, that the
system will shift in a way to
minimize that stress.
And to minimize that stress, you
would increase the partial
pressure by doing the shift
from one mole to two.
So again, this is Le Chatelier's
predictive, how
you would predict the direction
of the shift based
on the simple idea that a
system where a stress is
applied, the system will respond
in a way to minimize
the stress.
And again, I talked about last
time that this concept of
minimizing stress is difficult
for some MIT students, but you
just sort of have to memorize
that in this case we're
predicting how a system will
shift to minimize that stress.
OK.
So if you need a review
of partial
pressure, go over this.
This part, it looks a little
challenging at first, and some
of the questions you really have
to sit down and dissect
what's going on, and for most
people, once they get there,
that part, those are good
questions, you look forward to
them on the exam.
So now, we've talked about
adding reagents, we've talked
about removing reagents,
removing products, adding
products, shifts in volume, and
now we're going to talk
about changing the
temperature.
So here, Le Chatelier's
principle, it's a little bit
more fuzzy, but it still
basically works.
So if you talk about raising the
temperature of a mixture
at equilibrium, then Le
Chatelier's principle would
suggest that the system is going
to respond in such a way
to minimize that stress.
So if you're adding heat, the
system wants to respond in a
way to absorb some of the heat,
to counterbalance that
change to the system.
So let's take a look at this.
So let's think about raising
the temperature of an
exothermic reaction.
So what's going to
happen here?
Raising the temperature of an
exothermic reaction, favors
the formation of reactants,
would shift toward reactants.
Well, why would this be true.
Well, you can think about this
very simplistically that in an
exothermic reaction, you're
going to be producing heat in
the forward direction
and absorbing heat
in the reverse direction.
So if it's an exothermic
reaction, that means it's
exothermic in the forward
direction, which would mean it
was endothermic in the
reverse direction.
So if you raise the temperature
of an exothermic
reaction, you're adding heat,
the system wants to respond in
such a way to absorb that heat,
so it would shift toward
the endothermic direction of
the reaction, which is the
reverse direction toward
reactants.
So add heat, system wants
to shift to absorb
some of that heat.
So in this part you think about
the direction of the
reaction, whether it's
exothermic or endothermic, and
then think about compensating
for that stress.
Endothermic reaction, again,
they say it's an endothermic
reaction, it means
it's endothermic
in the forward direction.
So heat is being absorbed in the
forward direction -- again
this is just sort of a
very simplistic way
to think about it.
So if you raise the temperature
then, you want to
absorb that heat, according to
Le Chatelier's principle, and
so that would favor a shift
toward products.
So let's look some
more at this.
The predictive tool
here is delta h.
So delta h, whether the reaction
is exothermic or
endothermic, is going to be a
predictive tool in thinking
about the direction of change,
when heat is added to a system
or heat is removed
from a system.
So let's try this out.
Heat is added to a system.
You're given information about
your predictive tool, delta h.
Which direction will
the reaction go?
All right, 10 seconds.
Why don't you discuss with your
friends and vote again.
All right, 10 more seconds.
Yes!
I knew we could get
into the 90's.
All right, so what type of
reaction is this, endo or
exothermic?
Exothermic.
And so we're adding heat to an
exothermic reaction, so it
wants to shift to absorb that
heat, so it wants to go in
endothermic direction, which
is the reverse direction or
toward the reactants.
And that's how it's supposed to
work too, more people get
the right answer after
the group discusses.
All right.
So we've been talking about the
equilibrium constant so
far in terms of it being a
constant, it's called the
equilibrium constant, but it's
only constant at a given
temperature.
So the equilibrium constant
changes with temperature.
It's also true that rates
of reaction change with
temperature.
And kinetics is our last unit
in this course, and we'll be
discussing that quite a bit.
So how does the equilibrium
constant change with
temperature?
Let's consider that.
So let's look at some of the
equations that we know that
have delta h in them -- delta
h, again, is our predictive
factor when we're talking about
changes in temperature.
We know that delta g nought is
minus r t natural log of k, so
the relationship with our
standard free energy, our gas
constant temperature, and our
equilibrium constant.
We also know that delta g nought
equals delta h nought
minus t delta s nought.
If those equations don't look
familiar, then you should go
back and review the material
on thermodynamics because
you're going to need it in this
unit, the next unit, the
unit after that, and then the
next two units, and they we're
done with the class.
All right, so good to get
familiar with this now.
All right, so we can rearrange
these in terms of solving for
our equilibrium constant.
And so we see the natural log
of the equilibrium constant
minus delta h nought over r t,
plus delta s nought over r.
And so, it's reasonable to
assume that for the things
we're talking about, that delta
h nought and delta s
nought are pretty much
independent of temperatures.
That would be true for pretty
much any temperature we would
be talking about.
So that means that k, or the
natural log of k, is going to
change depending on
the temperature.
It won't change -- these other
ones are constant at all the
temperatures, so there's
a relationship between
equilibrium constant
and temperature.
So you can consider an
equilibrium constant at one
temperature, and an equilibrium
constant at
another temperature.
So we can talk about the natural
log of a k 2, of an
equilibrium constant 2, equal
to minus delta h over r t
temperature 2, plus delta
s nought over r.
We can do the same thing for
another temperature, another
temperature 1, equilibrium 1,
and if we subtract these two,
delta s is going to cancel out,
and we're going to get
this equation, which you know is
important because it has a
name, so this is the van't
Hoff equation.
And at some point later in the
course, I'll be asking you to
come up with this name, so I
always get very excited when
people can tell me it's a van't
Hoff equation later on,
not that that's on a test, but
there are very few equations
that have names.
So here we go.
So what does this do?
Well, we can talk about the
natural log of one equilibrium
constant over another, an
equilibrium constant k 2,
which is the equilibrium at
temperature 2, equilibrium
constant k 1, which is the
equilibrium constant at
temperature 1, is going to be
equal to minus delta h nought
over r, and then it depends
on the temperature.
So you bracket 1 over
temperature 2 minus 1 over
temperature 1.
And this just comes from
subtracting those 2 equations.
So again, you can think about
how the equilibrium constant's
going to change with temperature
-- that's what
this equation does for you.
So let's look at some of the
things that fall out of this
particular equation.
Let's think first about a case
where this delta h nought is
less than zero.
What type of reaction is that?
Exothermic.
All right, so now let's consider
a case for this
exothermic reaction where we're
going to increase the
temperature, and so that means
that t 2 will be greater than
t 1 -- we've increased
the temperature.
So now let's think about what
sign the natural log of k 2
over k 1 will have if these
things are true.
So there's a minus in the
equation, let's put
the minus down here.
Delta h nought is negative, it's
exothermic reaction, so
that's another negative sign.
And if we're increasing the
temperature, and t 2 is
greater than t 1, then this
temperature term will also
have and negative sign.
So if you have negative times
negative times negative,
you're going to get a negative
for your net result over here.
And what that will mean in terms
of k 2 and k 1, is that
k 1 will be greater than k 2.
So you can think about this
mathematically by running
through this argument.
You can also sort of think about
it in terms of what you
would expect if you increase
the temperature in terms of
what's the relative ratio of
products to reactants at
equilibrium for an exothermic
reaction.
So if you're increasing the
temperature of an exothermic
reaction, the reaction would
want to shift in the direction
to absorb that heat in the
endothermic direction.
So you would expect that the
equilibrium constant that was
at the lower temperature would
be larger than the higher
temperature one, that there'd
be less products at this new
higher temperature.
So again, you can think about it
in terms of Le Chatelier's
principle, or you can run
through with this equation and
do the math and think about
the relative size
of k 1 and k 2.
So now let's think about what
happens when you decrease the
temperature where t 2
is less than t 1.
So we can do the same thing, we
have a negative sign here,
we also have a negative sign
for delta h, it's an
exothermic reaction.
But now we have a positive
sign for
this temperature term.
So overall we're going to have
a positive sign for the
natural log of k 2 over k 1,
which mathematically is going
to mean that k 1 is less than
k 2 or that you would expect
more products in the equilibrium
constant at higher
temperature.
All right, so that's an
exothermic reaction.
So if you're ever having
problems with Le Chatelier,
you can go and use the van't
Hoff equation to think about
what you would expect in terms
of this shift, what you would
expect if you change the
temperature of an exothermic
reaction in terms of the
magnitude of the new
equilibrium constants.
All right, now you can do the
same for me in terms of this
delta h nought is greater
than zero.
Which of the following are going
to be true, and notice
there's a possibility that all
of them are true or that just
some of them are true or that
one of them is true.
All right, take 10
more seconds.
See, actually people did very
well, because e is also true,
all of those are true,
but d was also true.
So if we add the 30 and the 58
together, I'm very happy.
All right, so let's look at
this -- we'll keep the
questions up and let's consider
all of them in order.
So the first one is that the
reaction was endothermic, I
think everybody saw that
as being correct.
OK, the second one talked about
the equilibrium constant
is higher at higher
temperatures.
So let's look at
the first one.
We increased the temperature
here, and we see that if you
work out the math or just think
about it, k 2 is larger
than k 1, so the second
equilibrium constant is
greater than the first when you
increase the temperature.
So that would favor then, in an
endothermic direction, if
you're increasing the
temperature, it favors the
endothermic direction of the
reaction, so you could think
about the ratio having more
products at that new
equilibrium constant at that
higher temperature.
So that one was also true.
Then let's think about when you
decrease the temperature,
when temperature 1 is greater
than temperature 2.
And so this would favor, then,
the exothermic direction.
So you would expect less
products at this newer
temperature.
So, this part asked about k 1
versus k 2, and we see k 1 is
greater than k 2.
And then d says there's fewer
products and equilibrium when
the temperature is decreased,
and that's just the word way
of saying the same thing.
So all of those are true.
But again, people did very, very
well with this question.
All right.
So now we're going to combine
what we learned on Friday with
what we learned today, and think
about ways that that can
be applied.
So why should you care about
Le Chatelier's principle?
Well, for two reasons -- one I
think Le Chatelier had sort of
a good life plan that when
stress is applied to the
system, one should respond in a
way to minimize that stress.
I think that is an important
life lesson.
But also, it's very useful in
terms of thinking about
maximizing a yield
of a reaction.
So if you were going to create
an industrial process and make
lots of money and give some of
it back to MIT to improve
things in terms of teaching
chemistry at MIT, then you
would want to think about these
principles, because you
would want to maximize
your yield.
If you're going to be making a
product, you want to make a
lot of that product, and so you
want to be thinking about
these things.
So we've talked about the
reaction with nitrogen and
hydrogen making ammonia
last time.
And this is an exothermic
reaction.
So, there are a lot of people
who want to make ammonia --
it's for fertilizer, and as
some of you have heard in
terms of terrorism, it also can
be used as an explosive,
so there are a lot of
people who want to
make a lot of this.
So how do you maximize
this yield?
It's an exothermic reaction.
So you can think about
temperature.
So here, low temperature would
favor product, which is good.
We haven't talked about
kinetics yet, but low
temperature also slows the
rate, which is bad.
Because you not only want to
make a lot of your product,
you want to make it in a
reasonable time frame and sell
it and make lots of money
and retire early.
So you care about how fast the
reaction is going as well.
So for an exothermic reaction
then, you have to balance out
what's thermodynamically
favorable and what's
kinetically favorable.
So thermodynamically, you would
want a low temperature,
but kinetically in terms of the
rate, that's not so good.
So they use a compromised
temperature, which is 500
degrees c, so that's
pretty high
actually for this reaction.
So what are other things that
you could do to drive this
reaction toward products?
So yeah, what's something
else you could do?
STUDENT: Increase the volume.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you could think about
volume here.
So here we have four molecules
of gas on one side, and two
molecules of gas on
the other side.
So you can think about
changing that
to favor your products.
What is something else
you could do?
STUDENT: Enzymes.
PROFESSOR: Enzymes, we'll talk
about that in a minute.
If you can't use the enzymes,
what's something else
that you could do?
STUDENT: You could remove
ammonia from the system.
PROFESSOR: Yup, so you could
remove ammonia from the
system, which would also
shift the direction.
So let's just put those
two things down.
Remove products.
So if you remove ammonia from
the system, and they actually
do this in the industrial
process, so they'll stop --
they'll, at a certain time
points, they will remove the
product and they'll say
hey, let's shift the
reaction to make more.
You just changed q versus k, you
removed your product, so
now we want to shift to minimize
that stress and make
more product.
And the first response, compress
the volume, so we go
from four molecules to two
molecules, and that would be
favor -- again, the system would
want to respond, you
compressed the volume, you
increased the pressure, so you
want to respond in such a way
that compensates for that
increased pressure, which is
decrease the pressure by going
from the four molecules
to two.
So both of those are great,
and both of those are, in
fact, used.
Sometimes when you study
chemistry you'll realize that
some of the -- people made a lot
of money on this, and that
some of the principles are
actually very simple.
You are learning principles in
this class that, applied
correctly, could make
you a lot of money.
Some of the scientific
discoveries are actually not
all that complicated.
All right.
So someone said use enzymes.
I love that answer, I want to
use enzymes to do a lot of
those things, and people
are trying to do this.
Now, why would you want
to use an enzyme?
Well, there is a lot of nitrogen
in the air, but
there's not a lot of usable
nitrogen, because n 2 gas is
in the air, but it's very
difficult to break it apart to
form ammonia.
And when you think about
bonding, you can probably tell
me why it's hard to break n 2
apart, and if you consider how
many bonds would be between
those two nitrogens.
So it's there but
it's hard to do.
So the industrial process that's
used now pretty much is
the same industrial process
that's been used for quite a
while, the Haber-Bosch
process, which
does not use enzymes.
And here are some pictures
of these folks.
This resulted in two Noble
prizes, the development of the
industrial process here, and
it's still being used.
On a historic note, these were
German scientists, and so,
working out this process was
important to the Germans
during World War II.
It's still the process
going on today.
So what about enzymes.
Maybe enzymes could do a bit
better than this process.
It's not true yet.
Still the Haber-Bosch industrial
process is the one
that's being used, but
enzymes can do it.
So, some of the problems of a
lot of the common industrial
reactions are that you use high
temperatures -- remember
we said the compromised
temperature
was 500 degrees celsius.
We were talking about
compressing the volume, so you
want to put in energy to
compress that volume.
And so that is expensive.
And you might want to think
about a way, could you do that
reaction at normal ambient
temperature without applying
energy to the system.
Well, enzymes can do this
reaction at ambient
temperatures and they don't
have to have high pressure
associated with them, and the
way the enzymes do this, and
here's a little cartoon of a
space-filling model of a
particular enzyme called
nitrogenase.
So for nitrogen, and the ase
means it's an enzyme.
And the secret to this enzyme,
how it can do what Haber and
Bosch got two Nobel prizes for
-- this enzyme has received no
Nobel prizes, and it can
do the same thing.
Its secret are metals.
It uses these clusters of metals
in the context of the
protein environment to do this
chemistry, and they have iron,
and they have also inorganic
sulfide, and molybdenum, and
so these combinations of metals
can do this chemistry.
And a number of scientists have
been working for decades
now trying to understand
how the enzyme works.
It's actually quite complicated
and it's been
pretty controversial.
So let me just kind of show
you at the heart of the
enzyme, here all the atoms of
the enzyme, but if you rotate
the enzyme around and go in,
the secret was that those
combinations of metals.
And one of the units that we're
going to have second to
last in this courses is about
transition metals, that metals
can do a lot of really important
things in biological
systems, and also in industrial
processes and other
things as well.
So I do also like to
mention research is
going on here at MIT.
I've mentioned Dick Schrock
before, he won a Nobel Prize
in chemistry a few years back,
but not for his work on sort
of nitrogenase systems, but he
was able to design a small
catalyst that can do this
chemistry, that can catalyze
this reduction of nitrogen
to ammonia at a defined
molybdenum center.
Again, we'll talk about
transition metals
later in the course.
And so his laboratory is very
interested in coming up with
better ways to split nitrogen
than the industrial processes
that are currently used.
Some people are studying
enzymes, other people are
trying to use some of the
tools that come out the
enzymes, thinking about the
enzymes and come up with other
catalysts as well.
So this work is going
on here at MIT.
All right, so let's give one
more example of Le Chatelier
from a biological perspective,
and this has to do with the
following reaction.
The combination of oxygen with
hemoglobin in your blood.
And the reaction here, we have
hemoglobin plus oxygen has
oxyhemoglobin, so the oxygen is
now bound to be hemoglobin.
This reaction is very
important for you.
None of us would be alive if
this was not happening.
We need to get the oxygen from
our lungs to our cells.
So what happens if you
decide to climb Mount
Everest, for example.
You may be thinking how hard
can that be after a first
semester freshman year at MIT.
Really, I can think more
broadly about it.
All right, how many of
you have climbed
a mountain so far?
Woah, a lot of people.
OK, something about going to MIT
and climbing big mountains
seems to be connected.
How many people feel like after
surviving the first
year, why not, go ahead
and climb a mountain?
Any more people?
OK, no.
So you gotta -- you've been
through the hard part now, you
don't want to risk
anything anymore.
All right, so this slide seems
to be cutting off some stuff,
so let's look over here.
So what happens to
this reaction?
Well, as you go up higher and
higher, the partial pressure
of oxygen changes.
So you're going to drop in
partial pressure 0.2 to 0.14 .
So what happens to
this reaction
if this value decreases?
What happens, what direction
does it shift?
For products or reactants?
Right.
So, if this is going down, then
some of your oxygenated
hemoglobin is going to
a release its oxygen.
So it'll respond in such
a way to compensate
for that added stress.
So what can you do to switch
it back the other way?
Again, we want our blood
to be oxygenated.
What happens to compensate for
this if you're going to climb
a mountain?
What happens in the body?
Yeah.
STUDENT: The body can produce
more hemoglobin.
PROFESSOR: The body can produce
So you often go to another
altitude and hang out for a
while before you start
going way up.
And what's happening during
that time is your body
realizes there is a problem,
it knows about the Le
Chatelier's principle, and so
it's going to make more
hemoglobin.
And if you add more hemoglobin
to this reaction, what
direction does it go?
Toward products, right.
OK.
So I wanted to mention
significant figures,
and there is --
I have to make a confession
that when I first started
teaching this course, I had
never really paid attention to
the rules of significant
figures for logs.
In this unit, the next unit,
the unit after, you get the
idea, there are going to be a
lot of logs, and they have
special rules for significant
figures.
So in the bottom of your
handout, these rules are
explained, it's also
in your book.
Pay attention to this.
It's going to help
you on all the
problem-sets and in the course.
So I just wanted to point
out special rules about
significant figures for logs.
All right, that's it for today,
see you on Wednesday.